- Un cocktail sans alcool p p pu
de piquant dans la soirée
des conducteurs désignés.
C'est l'essence du programmeiee
lancé sur la Rive-Sud.
Le Balthazar, qui avait déjà
adopté cette pratique depuisnnne
accepté de se joindre à
l'initiative.
VINCENT HAMELIN-LORD, gérant,th0
- On offre des mojitos
sans alcool, des bloody ceasar
sans alcool. On a plusieurcococn
offre aux gens qui se portent
volontaire pour aider
leurs amis, là.
-
les conducteurs désignés
n'ont qu'à s'identifier.
On leur remet un bracelet,
puis ils peuvent obtenir
pendant que leurs amis
se laissent aller.
La seule condition : ramener
au moins deux personnes
à la maison.babababababababababs
nous suivent là-dedans,
vraimentssssssayer d'encourager
plus une consommation saine,
entre paranthèses. Pas
mais surtout de ne pas se mettre
ananananger dans l'immédiat,
ne pas aller se mettre
sur la route quand on est
- Le programme, qui a vu le jour
à Sherbrooke il y a cinq ans,
est aussi en place à Gatineau
et à Laval.a a a a police de Lot
la tournée des bars et des
restaurants de l'agglomérati
participer.
Sur 150 établissements visités,
une trentaine ont accepté.
VALE
- On trouvait que c'était
un moment propice à partir
le projet, le temps des Fêtes,
les partys de bureaux et tout.
projet seulement pour le temps
des Fêtes, c'est vraiment
à l'année.
tous les conducteurs désignés,
rtrtrtrtrte l'âge, mais
on cible surtout les jeunes.
- C'est une bonne idée.
d'avoir un chauffeur, dans lefo,
puis ça lui permet de consommer
quelque chose pendant laxixixix.
60 $, des fois, le taxi
pour retourner.
- Dans les tranches d'âge de
18 à 25 ans, malheureusement,
il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de conduite avecles ca,
fait qu'on essaye de faire
diminuer ces statistiquerererers
établissements entreront
dans la danse.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Brossar